foreign
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive now in the
next half an hour we'll see what's
making headlines with the journalists
Christina Patterson and Ali Mirage Let's
uh take a look at what's on some of
those front pages we'll start with the
front page of the telegraph which leads
with reports that the prime minister's
decision to appoint Christopher pincher
to help oversee party discipline
prompted the resignation of Craig
Whitaker another senior whip the Sunday
Times also leads with the upset caused
by Chris pincher's alleged actions who's
spoken to an anonymous source who claims
they were groped by Mr pincher
the Sunday Mirror claims that the Prime
Minister missed chances to investigate
Mr pincher after being warned about his
behavior previously
The Observer reports that the
government's official spending watchdog
is to launch an inquiry into the prime
minister's claims that 40 new hospitals
will be built by 2030
the express claims that a cabinet battle
is underway with ministers urging Boris
Johnson to cut taxes now
and the Daily Star tells British people
to wash less to avoid water shortages as
hot weather is on the horizon
and a reminder that by scanning that QR
code that you see on your screen during
the program you can check out tomorrow's
front pages while we talk through them
all right now let's bring in our guests
this evening the journalists Christina
Patterson and Ali Mirage Christina Ali
good evening to you lovely to have you
with us thank you for being with us so
let's start off
um with you uh Ali we'll start with the
front page of the telegraph this is uh
the headline there is we can see the the
Prime Minister apparently turned a blind
eye to warnings about Christopher
pincher
well this is a story uh Kamali that's
been running the telegraph talking about
the fact that Craig Whitaker who was
also in the whips office another
conservative mp uh raised issues back in
February when the reshuffle took place
which brought Chris pincher back into
the cabinet office uh sorry back into
the whips on his Deputy uh whip
um Craig Whitaker actually raised an
issue until he was uncomfortable and
resigned his own position and did not
want to remain in the whips office now
this comes on the back of a number of
allegations that have been uh made
against Chris pincer some going back to
2017 another one in 2018 and then
obviously the latest issue that happened
on Friday at the at the Carlton Club
where apparently uh we understand that
that two people were sort of
inappropriately approached by uh Chris
pincher to put it politely there has to
be an investigation into this but based
on the fact that pincher himself has
recused himself of his position uh and
uh the whip has now been withdrawn bill
relatedly by the Prime Minister I do
think it calls into question of how long
Chris pitcher can survive as an MP
particularly when you look at what
happened to Neil Parrish um who was
allegedly looking up tractors and ended
up looking at porn in the chamber of the
House of Commons who had to be forced
out
um of Parliament and his seat just was
contested in a by-election and Imran
Ahmed Khan again another mp uh recently
forced out for child sexual abuse so
this comes on the back of a really
touring period for the party and it's
beginning to get this reputation of
being increasingly sleazy which is
unfair because most politicians are just
going about doing their jobs and trying
to do the best of their ability but this
looks really bad and I think Chris
pincher unfortunately should uh consider
his position really here thank you for
that ali uh Christine Let's uh move on
to the front page on Sunday times it's
the same story but I just want you to
sort of pick up on the reporting that
we're getting from the times there they
say they've spoken to the person who was
allegedly groped by Mr pincher saying he
was Furious and shell-shocked
yes well I mean if you want to assemble
for this ghastly sleaze ridden lying
sexually assaulting drunken government
then really you couldn't do much better
or worse arguably then then this this
rather ghastly man because
um there have been a series of
allegations I think there are now six
more allegations of a sexual assault
let's call it a Spader Spade here it's
not I mean groping makes it sound sort
of you know rather innocent the
accusation here is of something really
very explicit and unpleasant essentially
grabbing somebody essentially in their
genitals now that is not a mild thing to
do it's not harmless and the idea that
you can issue a statement saying that
you embarrassed yourself as if that was
some kind of justification that you
drank a bit much and you're slightly
embarrassed about the whole thing no
you're not slightly embarrassed this
that's a crime sexual assault
um you know is I mean that is not
something that should be allowed to
happen in any workplace and there is
every indication that this has since
there are repeated allegations that this
has happened repeatedly and not only
that but that the Prime Minister was
warned on at least two occasions about
his history and not only that but that
he joked about it the story at hand for
this evening if we can please just uh
the allegations against Mr pincher at
the stage
well the allegations against Mr pincer
yes as I said there are there are
allegations of six more in six more
people who say that they have
um experienced uh his sexual misbehavior
and he is yet another Tori MP who was
refusing to resign and saying he's
seeking medical help as if he is the
victim here I mean that is an absolute
habit of this government that when
something goes wrong they think they are
the victims they're not the people who
are suffering from their alleged
misbehavior so I mean I I have to say I
don't think this one is just going to
fade from you there's just Scandal upon
Scandal upon Scandal and I I'm sorry Ali
but I don't think you're right when you
say that it gives a misleading
impression to call this government
sleazy this government is Sleazy and at
the moment I think one in eight
um MPS there are allegations of some
kind of sexual misbehavior male MPS that
is an incredibly High number for any
workplace there is something deep deeply
wrong with the culture of Westminster
and in particularly please there are a
large number of MPS who are under these
investigations 56 I think if my memory
Services correctly that that's that's
right there 56 and we don't know if
they're all Tories or not look and to
just make it clear I'm not saying that
the government is easy or not sleepy and
I've got a lot of problems with the
government particularly around the whole
party gate issue and the fact that an
example is not being set by the Prime
Minister I think you should have done a
decent thing and gone but he's not going
to do the decent thing he's got the
height of a rhinoceros and he sets the
example from the top so I'm not
defending the government in essence I'm
just saying that not every one of the
650 MPS in Parliament is going around
engaging in this kind of behavior a lot
of them are just getting on with their
job under difficult circumstances and
trying to do the best for their
constituents in the country right
however there is a an issue here
specifically with Chris pincher and also
with the potentially with the 56 others
where you could point to is it a
drinking culture that's not an excuse
frankly you know are you Christian in
your right in this sense and if it
wasn't any other Walk of Life you would
have to resign we'd have to resign your
job which is exactly why I think Chris
pinch's position even based on what we
know before the investigations happened
really given the fact he's himself a
resigned his position I think it's going
to be untenable for him to stay as an MP
okay Ali Christina thank you for that
let's move on to the front page of the
Observer now Christina you pick up on
this if you can please this is a a an
official probe as the Observer calls it
into this plan for 40 new Hospitals now
anyone who's been paying attention to
pmqs for the past couple of weeks will
have noticed that every time these new
hospitals is discussed there are sort of
rules of a derision from the labor
benches what's all this uh about in The
Observer Today Christina well this was a
Manifesto Promise by the Tory party to
build 40 new hospitals and then it
turned out that basically if you put a
kind of Porter cabin next to an existing
hospital then according to their
um assertions that will qualify as a new
hospital extensions
um you know little car Parks I mean
apparently practically anything camps as
a new hospital and the National Audit
office uh wants to see investigate this
and see a whether what they're actually
doing offers value for money to for the
taxpayer and B whether it's an accurate
assertion that they are providing 40 new
hospitals by 2030 and uh so far it
doesn't look as if they are so I'm glad
and it's a serious thing for Boris
Johnson because it's one thing to
constantly lie to the electorate as he
does but it's another to have this
investigated by the National Audit
office which is a very serious body this
isn't a political matter it's an
independent Financial matter so we'll
see what happens but you know it looks
like another lie that's about to be
uncovered well Ali just pick up on this
then if you can because uh regardless of
how this inquiry actually does turn out
another inquiry into Boris Johnson and
the government it will not be welcome
right now
no that's right I mean this seems to be
inquiry after inquiry at the moment this
has been instigated as I understand it
by West streeting the shadow uh Health
secretary who is a rising star of the of
the labor party
um and potentially wants to become
leader so we understand at some point
um it looks like a comptroller in order
to General is looking into this National
Audit office is an independent body that
is going to conduct this review and the
the thing that this throws up Kamali for
me is that there is a difference between
the government announcing things and
actually delivering you could see this
in the Rwanda policy I thought you know
perfectly understanding a lot of people
against it but something had to be done
but again yet again even with that
example there's a difference between
announcing something and actually
getting it done and bringing it into
practice and again here 14 new hospitals
by 2030 as Christina says we understand
that a lot of these things are not
really proper new hospitals and look
Sergey Javed who's the health secretary
you know perfectly credible decent
hard-working person uh we needs to be a
little bit careful about how this is
marketed because frankly it's a question
of credibility in a government at the
moment that to me seems to be decaying
quite rapidly for a whole host of
reasons
um and this is just not helpful at all
they're certainly not at this stage Ali
Christina for now thank you so much for
that we'll be back with you very shortly
we're going to go to a short break now
of course we'll continue the Press
preview featuring uh this story on the
Sunday Times the headline reads Prince's
honor for Tycoon who bailed out his
failed Eco Village more map after the
break
[Music]
hello and welcome back you're watching
the Press preview I'm joined by the
journalists Christina Patterson and Ali
Mirage Christina Ali thanks for staying
with us Christine let's pick up on the
front page of the Sunday Times their
main story tomorrow morning uh the
headline there is we can see Prince's
honor for Tycoon who bailed out his
failed Eco Village of course this news
comes on the back of the uh reporting
from just a week or so ago that Prince
Charles was given bags of cash by a
former Qatari prime minister
yes it's um it's a rather a depressing
story actually because
um essentially it's extremely rich man
asks another extremely rich man to uh
give him money for what turns out to be
a failed project and gives him an honor
uh as some kind of anticipatory reward
but um the kind of big coincidence is
that the extremely rich man who Prince
Charles is asking to or has asked had
asked for funds for an Eco Village that
he built is also the extremely rich man
that Boris Johnson asked to pay for the
gold wallpaper at Downing Street and
also asked apparently to pay for 150 000
pounds tree house for his toddler at
Checkers I mean the whole thing is so it
sounds so surreal that it feels as if it
has to be nonsense but apparently it
isn't nonsense apparently people really
do go around our prime minister goes
around wanting gold Roll paper and 150
Grand tree houses and Prince Charles who
is extremely rich and wants to wanted
money for um a village that he was
building around a mansion called
Dumfries house City Board and also lent
that Mansion to Lord Brown loaf his 50th
birthday celebrations so the whole thing
the whole thing sounds absolutely mad
but unfortunately it does seem to
exhibit very bad judgment on behalf of
Prince Charles who was advised not to
touch him with a barge pole but
unfortunately went ahead and the Eco
Village failed because there was not
enough demand for the houses but
apparently Lord Brownlow has continued
to be given contracts by the charitable
Foundation involved to the prince's
charitable Foundation involved with the
village so the whole thing is a bit of a
mess but it costs a heavy Shadow over
the reputation of the heir to the throne
at a time when you know I frankly it'd
be helpful not to have that and
Christina and Clarence House have said
at the end of this reporting that uh all
sort of measures were properly followed
so there's nothing untoward in this
situation but Ali as Christian was
saying that this does sort of um bring
back to the attention this idea at the
edge of the throne the man who will be
king soon
um has perhaps made some bad decisions
in the past that perhaps you won't make
in the future
Prince Charles I think he's a an
intelligent man thoughtful uh very well
read and cares about the job he does
however uh this kind of thing does smack
of a of a lack of judgment and I think
he is going to have to be extremely
careful going forward it was only a few
days ago that we heard about the the you
know the the 500 pound notes uh in the
in the in the in the suitcase stuffed
from some Qatari shake these kind of
things uh do not look good and you
cannot have a situation where there is
any perception whatsoever be it correct
or incorrect that uh honors of any kind
of conferred for uh donations and also
anything like that has to be declared
openly related party transactions for a
charity need to be declared properly I'm
sure Prince Charles will be paying close
attention to this going forward okay
thank you for that alien just uh quickly
then before we go to the break Christina
let's look at page two of the express
this is all about travel k us at the
airports this Summer that we're
expecting lines of bags there but uh
help is at hand because the recruits are
now going to be put on a fast track tell
us about this
well I really hope so because I I feel
so sorry for all the people who've been
trying to get away for uh for breaks and
and you know after having waited a long
time and airports are absolute chaos at
the moment and there's an awful lot of
lost luggage sitting around apparently
abandoned and and you know it's
miserable to miss your flight it's
miserable to have a flight Council it's
miserable I apologize for interrupting
you but I've run out of time I should
never put that question to you anyway
all right